they're oftentimes referred to as the
greatest integer function and it can be
represented by this symbol here okay or
this symbol here notice the little bars
at the bottom sometimes called a floor
function okay and basically what a
greatest integer function does is it
rounds down to the next greatest integer
so I'll show you an example like say for
example we wanted to simplify to point
five okay well if you think of the
number line like here's enough here's
two right here and here's three right
here right two point five is right about
in the middle right so when we round
down we're rounding to two so this is
going to equal two that's the next
integer
you know below now if you wanted to
figure out what this is we'll say the
greatest integer of let's say 1 well
this would just still be one okay so it
just rounds down to the next integer but
if it's already an integer it's gonna
stay that value now say for example it
was like a negative value this is where
students sometimes I go off the track so
to speak negative 4.5 so if we look at a
number line here okay here's negative
4.5 well here's negative 4 here's
negative 3 here's negative 5 and here's
0 way over here right so negative 4.5 is
right about here but notice we're
rounding down rounding down or rounding
to the left so you always round to the
left on the number line so this is
actually negative 5 sorry with me so far
it looks like the numbers getting larger
and you said hey wait a second Mario you
said we round down well you are rounding
down negative 5 is actually smaller than
negative four point five because it's
further to the left on the number line
okay so are you with me so far ok so the
next thing is we're going to talk about
how to graph these step functions the
first thing I would recommend doing is
let's just make a table of values so
what I'll do is make a little table I'm
gonna pick some integer values like 0
that's gonna round down to 0.5 that
rounds down to 0.99 still 0 1 is going
to be 1 ok 1.5 we're on down to 1 1.999
we round down to one but two we're gonna
be at - okay and so on so if we plot
these points okay let's see if we can
draw this here one two three okay you
can see zero zero that's going to be
right here
zero zero point five is going to be
right here is 0.99 that's zero but as
soon as we get to one okay we jump up to
one see this is the point 1 1 so what we
have here is we have a step so you can
see where it's you know we're the step
function name comes from okay so you go
up to your you jump up to 11.5 you're
gonna be at 1 1 point 9 9 they're gonna
be at 1 at 2 there's an open circle here
right because it jumps up to the next
integer okay so that's the next stair
and once you get a few of these stairs
or steps going you can repeat the
process okay you know like so both
directions all right so you're with me
so far now this is a function because it
passes the vertical line test notice
like right here it's open here closed
here so it's only crossing the graph at
one point so this is how you graph the
basic graph and I just want to show you
how to do a couple transformations of
this function here so say you wanted to
graph y equals 2 okay like this 2 times
what do you think this 2 does to the
graph well if you said that it stretches
it vertically by 2 times you're
absolutely right so basically what this
is going to happen now is instead of
these stairs being going up one each
time they're going to go up 2 okay so if
I can sketch that let's see I'll put it
right down here it's gonna look
something like this now you're gonna
jump up to 2 then you're gonna jump up
to 4 okay and you're gonna jump down to
negative 2 so it's a vertical stretch by
2 so we're multiplying all the y-values
by 2 now what would happen do you think
if I put the two grouped okay with the X
well if you said that it's going to be a
horizontal compression you're absolutely
right the thing to remember is that when
it's grouped with the X it has the
opposite effect okay so for another
example like say for example we have X
minus 2
you see the -2 and you might naturally
think well -2 means left-to-right but
when it's grouped with the X it has an
opposite effect this is actually gonna
shift the graph right - so you're gonna
pick the graph up ok this graph here
pick it up you're going to shift it two
units to the right whereas this one here
we're just going to multiply all the x's
by 1/2 and so what's going to happen is
it's going to compress it horizontally
so these stairs are actually just going
to be let's see if I can sketch that
here for you they're just going to be
like 1/2 then it's gonna jump up to the
next one ok like that so basically it's
compressing this way so I hope this
helped you to understand how to graph
the step functions ok also known as the
greatest integer function take a look at
some of these examples here and I also
have a video that talks about the
different transformations that we're
talking about here if you want to learn
more about that and I can put a link for
that for you
so subscribe to the channel check out
some of my other videos on Mario's math
tutoring YouTube channel and I look
forward to seeing in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon